[Music]
happily married for 28 years
28 years that's uh that's quite a
stretch how how's married life
you still very good how long are you
home C's 14 I think 14 years I like how
I get nothing someone says 20 then I go
14 and people just like you I'm crying I
took that away I took it away from you
with 28 but 14 is big I remember but
yeah it's not much different at 14
you're still it's for me it's all about
points it's all about scoring points
when I can mm-hmm because it's all I
don't know what game were in with you
ladies but but you have the lead all the
time and I actually did something the
other day I scored some good points I
drove my wife to her her colonoscopy I'm
probably gonna lose points by telling
the story but it was a routine routine
there's over to get the co nos yeah it
was there was just a check-up routine
nothing wrong and the doctor said come
back in two hours you know because she
gets put out you know so I Drive in
around us in Beverly Hills and I passed
this it's like a candle perfume shop and
I just thought to myself I'm gonna score
some points I'm gonna I'm gonna pick up
a little gift a little picking you up
from your colonoscopy yeah yes and I go
in the store and there's a nice young
woman nobody's in there a nice young
woman behind the counter and she was
kinda help you I go yeah I wanna just
get a little gift from my wife and she
looks me well that's pretty nice
what's the occasion and I said I
immediately knew I have to lie to this
woman and and I came out pretty quick I
was like I'm picking her up from the
airport I was pretty proud of myself
yeah yeah but then she followed it up
with a wish coming in from yes and I was
very quick on this one but not as good I
said Germany
yes I don't know why yeah I said Germany
because Germany is gonna she's gonna ask
questions now yes it was horrible
here's the thing here's what I figured
out when you have to lie fast cuz when
you're married for 20 years you have to
lie fast oh yeah guys but that's what
happened you know you don't have time to
the brain sent Germany if I had time I
would just think about it and you know
no give me another word brain but no you
don't have here you're my lips are
forming a word already Germany comes
down the lips grab it the lips throw it
out and then the the ears kind of giggle
a little you know oh he screw it up oh
that is that's bad Germany because sure
enough she was like oh she has relatives
in Germany and I was like I can't I
can't and I just felt like I'm not
picking up I'm I'm going to the cemetery
wasn't that a great clip subscribe to my
youtube channel for an endless supply of
me
[Laughter]